I started to introduce all those topics
because I was trying to address the
issue of how it is that we've come to
deal with the fact that things are so
complex that we can't deal with them and
so a huge part of the answer to that is
the Darwinian answers.
One is while you keep up with things
you can't keep up with by changing
unpredictably.
So here's an example.
You know sometimes if you're driving
down the road and there's a deer on the
road,
maybe you'll run into it and it'll
instead of jumping out of the way,
it sort of jumps randomly
and then you run into it.
You think,
well that's a pretty stupid strategy.
It's like natural selection at work there,
but it turns out that deer jump
randomly when wolves are chasing them.
Well,
why would you do that?
because you can't predict it,
right?
If,
if something horrible is after you
acting unpredictably is actually a pretty
good strategy and that's basically
what mutation does means.
The horrible thing that's after you
always is the rapid transformation of the
environment and the only thing you can
possibly do in that in that case is
capitalize on chance.
Okay,
so that's one thing.
So that's partly why the Darwinian
story I think has to be right,
because the environment does
move unpredictably and the
only way you can keep up
with something that's unpredictable,
to generate variance and hope that one
of them has drawn the lucky lottery card,
but then there's these additional
issues which is that we're also.
We also seem to be tightly selected for
the capacity to cooperate and compete.
So that multiplies our cognitive ability.
That's a huge part of it.
And then we're also.
We also seem to have
constructed ourselves,
so to speak,
through sexual choice into
these general problem,
general purpose,
problem solving creatures.
And so we've internalized
some of the Darwinian process.
So you think,
well,
most animals will produce a variance of
themselves physically and then most of
those variants die,
but human beings have built A.
Lance built a mechanism,
let's say that's like a game engine.
I think that's a really good.
You know how there are game engines
now that people have devised their,
their computational devices and you can
take a game engine and you can generate
games with it like computer games.
So I'm the game engine is a
mechanism for producing games.
Well,
that's what our brains are like.
Our brains are game engines for producing
games and so what happens is that when
you think you produce
an Avatar of yourself,
you produce a fictional world and that
that Avatar and habits and maybe you
produce multiple fictional
worlds in multiple avatars,
that's the EU that could be tomorrow,
which is what you're doing when you're
planning and you walk the Avatar through
its potential routes and those that look
good and you keep and those that don't
look good,
you kill and so you can.
Then you can embody the ideas that you
keep an act those out and hopefully the
idea is that when you embody them,
you're successful and
you don't get killed.
And so we're select.
We've also seen that when
we've been selecting each
other for cognitive prowess,
we've been selecting ourselves for
the ability to generate avatars out of
ourself and kill them instead of dying.
It's unbelievably brilliant.
And,
and that's really akin to the
human discovery of the future.
Right?
The future is a place where
variance of you could exist.
It's something like that and other
animals don't seem to be able to do that.
So we're very sneaky.
And while so far doesn't
seem to be working too badly,
although we haven't been
around for very long,
right?
I mean human beings of our particular
sub species about 150,000 years,
something like that,
which is from an evolutionary timeframe.
It's like it's nothing,
you know,
it's 2080 year old man.
It's not very long,
you know,
if you think about it that way.
Okay.
So
now what I want to do is
draw a relationship between
that developmental process,
that evolutionary process and the
emergence of these underlying motivational
systems.
It's something like this.
So you imagine you go back in time to
the emergence of the development of
nervous systems.
So there's cells that creatures
use to do produce motor output,
and there are cells that creatures use
to map the patterns around them onto
themselves.
And so those are that sensory.
That's the sensory layer,
so to speak.
Imagine sensory layer,
nervous layer,
motor layer.
In simpler animals,
you just have sensory motor cells.
Then they diversify sensory layer,
nervous layer,
motor layer.
In fact,
that's actually what you consist of
when you're first developing in utero.
After the blast site stage,
when your cells differentiate,
that's the differentiation.
Sensory layer,
nervous layer,
motor layer.
So then you think there's a sensory layer.
Now what's that sensory layer doing?
Think about the world as consists
consisting of patterns of all sorts,
like maybe there's an animal in the
ocean and it's being subjected to wave
motion,
and so it's sensory systems map the
wave motion onto the motor output.
So if you look at a sponge,
for example,
sponges are good examples because they're
sort of half unicellular animals and
half multicellular animals.
You can take a sponge and run it through
a colander and separate it out into
cells,
say in salt water,
and it'll assemble itself
back into a sponge.
So it sort of at the.
Yeah,
amazing.
Hey,
it's kind of what you do in Utero.
It sells somehow know enough to
communicate with another to one another to
organize themselves into an organism's.
It's unbelievable.
We have no idea how people do that because
when you're in the initial form blast
site form,
all those cells are identical
genetically and then all of a sudden they
differentiate and they moved other
places they're supposed to go.
We have no idea how that.
How the hell can that happen?
These cells,
they're all identical
except for their position,
so they're obviously communicating
with one another in some unbelievably
complicated way and saying,
well,
you know this sort of sell it and so
you're going to differentiate that way.
God only knows,
but anyway,
sponges can do this.
Now,
a sponge isn't complicated enough to
have the sensory layer and the service
layer and the motor layer.
It's just sensory motor cells,
if I remember correctly,
but what the sponge is trying to figure
out is it wants to get water through its
pores inside because that's how it eats
and so there's wave motion constantly
and so what's happening is the wave motion
is a pattern and the sponges reacting
to that in a patterned
way and that's a really.
It's really useful to think about what
you're responding to as patterns instead
of objects because we
think we react to objects,
but objects are actually a specific
subcategory of pattern and so because they
don't also helps to explain perception.
It's like,
well,
what does it mean for
you to see something?
Well,
it means a bunch of things,
but one of the things that means
is when I look at that thing,
it manifests itself to
me as a grippable object.
I mean that that's built
into the way I see it.
So if you think about the way that
you see that on the surface there,
you can tell that it's separate from
the surface because it has a bit of a
shadow and it's a different color and
it's obviously shaped for a hand and so
that thing tells you when you look
at it that it's the grabbable object.
Well it's,
it's hand shaped like a stone tool would
be and so and all the things around you
in the world manifest themselves as
patterns of utility that that's the
appropriate way to think about it.
You say,
well,
what does this thing mean?
Because that's a hard question.
Well,
one of the things that your eyes do,
it's like,
imagine you've got this representational
surface at the back of your retina.
It's made out of pixels,
roughly speaking,
right?
Those are the cells and what it does
is map that pattern onto your retinal
pattern and then the retinal pattern
propagates itself as a nervous pattern
loan.
Your optic nerve.
And then that manifests itself as a
neurological pattern and that neurological
pattern manifests itself
as an action pattern.
And so the meaning of the object is the
action pattern that is mapped onto the,
onto the percept.
And so what does this mean?
This is what it means.
I think this is a Piagetian observation.
It's like wonder many
one,
right?
Because I'm acting like it's one,
but if I do this
then it's many y one,
two,
right there separately
manipulable entities.
And so the concept of number
is in fact predicated,
at least in part
on the idea of singular usability.
But you're mapping.
It's like,
well what is this?
It's a key.
Well,
what does that mean?
I mapping that shape into this
motion for that action say,
well,
it's not just a key,
it's a weapon,
right?
And so that's because I've mapped
it onto a different output pattern.
But if you think about perception as
the matching of patterns onto patterns,
it makes,
it makes way more sense.
You can really start thinking
about how perception works,
because then you can also start
thinking about unconscious perception.
So you know the,
the blind sight experiments
show for example,
that if,
if you've had cortical damage,
so you think you're blind,
you can't see objects anymore,
but I show you a picture
of a frightened face,
you'll show us in skin conductance
response to it and you think,
well,
how the hell can that happen?
It's like I have to see the face in order
to infer the emotion in order to have
the reaction.
It's like,
no,
you don't.
You don't need that at all.
You need a pattern recognition system
that maps that right onto an amygdala
output that produces
physiological readiness.
You don't need the perceptible
entity because you know,
you think you see something and then
you think about the thing and then you
evaluate the thing and then you act.
It's like you do do that.
But there are parts of you
that don't do that at all.
Way Faster parts,
more primordial parts.
And so another example would be Darwin's
trick with the snake that I told you
about.
He'd go to this museum that had a
cobra in a glass cage and the Cobra,
he'd put his face up to the glass cage
and the Cobra would strike out him and
he'd go like this,
and there was no way
he could control that.
Well,
it's because the part of him that saw
the snake wasn't the part that was doing
this.
There's a part of him
that does this to snakes.
That's what it does and it's.
It's way faster than the per unit figure,
the to see the snake
you have to the images.
Obviously the image,
the pattern is portrayed on the
retina propagates backwards to see it.
It has to be elaborated up through
a very complex set of neurological
connections that takes time.
And so your dad.
Well,
the thing that snake means this,
that's like three neurons super fast
and so what is a snake at that level of
representation?
It's like a snake is that which makes
you do this and then you could also say
that at that level of representation,
everything that makes you
do this is the same thing,
right?
Because the same would be defined by the
pattern that you manifest in response
to that entity,
so then your nervous
system is layered very,
very sensory layer neurological layer,
motor layer.
As you become more complex,
the sensory layer differentiates into
the different sensory systems and the
neurological level multiplies in terms
of its potential number of connections.
So what happens is that you can map
patterns that manifest themselves in
multiple different ways,
in multiple different ways
to multiple motor outputs.
So you start with a fixed action pattern,
which is just like this.
The the sponge reflects
what's the world to a sponge.
The world is what makes you
go like this or like that.
That's it.
That's the whole world.
The sponge has compressed
the entire world into pores,
open pores closed.
That's,
that's it to states.
And then once the nervous system gets
differentiated and the senses get
differentiated,
so there's specialized kinds of cells,
then you can detect
more forms of patterns.
You can produce more
patterned output to that,
but even more interestingly,
and this is where the nervous
system starts to come into play,
the mapping of the pattern onto
the output is no longer one to one.
You can use the same pattern
roughly speaking to British,
all sorts of different outputs that are
context dependent because you might say,
well,
so okay,
I picked that up and you say,
well,
he picked that up.
It's okay.
Well what about that?
You think,
well,
he picked it up.
Well,
yeah,
I did.
Except that the pattern of musculature
that I used to do this is by no means
identical to the pattern of
musculature that I used to do that.
Right?
I mean the fact that the orientation is
different is actually extraordinarily
important.
So,
so.
Well,
my point is,
is that right?
We're sufficient nervous complexity.
You can take the same thing,
so to speak and map it all sorts of
different ways and human beings are
unbelievably good at that.
Okay,
so now go back to when things were simple.
So there's single celled
organisms will say,
and then they start to differentiate to
some degree and they start to propagate
and so then there's the environment
starts to shift because the fact of the
prevalence of all of these competitors
means the environment isn't exactly the
same as it was when that
system first evolved,
new problems emerge and so then there's
selection pressure on those creatures to
diversify to some degree and then the
diversification produces a transformation
in the environment and then
there's pressure on those
new entities to diversify
some more.
And so you get this weird
bootstrapping process.
Maybe the environment is one
thing when there's 10 of you,
but a completely different thing
when there's a thousand of you.
Right?
So just sheer multiplication is
going to transform the environment.
And so then the.
Because the environment has now become
more complex than it was their selection
pressure to produce diversification
in the underlying organisms.
And that took a long time
to get off the ground.
Like there were single celled
organisms for a huge span of history.
I mean,
if you look at evolutionary history,
the amount of time that there were single
celled organisms is far longer than
the time that there's been since
the remotely celled organisms.
It's like it's like Moore's law.
You know the law that governs the,
the increase in computational power.
You can trace that back
to about the year $1,400,
something like that.
So it's been going on for a very long
time and maybe you could make the same
case from an evolutionary perspective.
It's like the flat part of
the curve is really long,
but once it starts to move up,
it starts to move up really
fast and obviously that's
the position that we're in
now.
So single celled
organisms for a long time.
Then they started to diversify
and then you could imagine,
well
from the single cell organism,
you start getting multicellular
organism and then it ends up with this
tripartite structure,
sensory layer,
nervous layer,
motor layer,
and then that starts to differentiate
and every time there's a differentiation
that's conserved and that's these systems.
The motivational systems.
He emerged a long,
long time ago as emergent solutions to
emergent problems and you've conserved
all of them.
I mean you've conserved your snake reflex,
which is like three neurons long,
so that's really,
really primordial,
but you've conserved,
you've conserved function at
almost every temporal level,
so there's parts of you that are quick
and dirty and parts of you that are slow
and sophisticated and a lot of the
contents of consciousness is slow and
sophisticated,
so it can't help you out in an emergency,
but it can do or consciousness
seems to do is take your structure,
it analyzes the world's for,
for let's say,
mismatches between what you
want and what's happening,
and then it either helps you alter the
world so those mismatches go away or it
turns inward.
Ma modifies the structures
that you're using.
So if you're playing the piano,
you've got this automatized routine has
very little to do with consciousness.
If you've practiced enough
and you make a mistake,
you stop and you note the mistake,
you stop and then you slow
it down and then you read.
You practice the new thing.
Then you speed it up.
Then you speed it up,
then you speed it up and
as you're doing that,
the neural representation shrinks until
you've developed this little specialized
machine and then you run that a few
times and now you can ignore it.
You can look at the notes and
just play and away you go,
and that's kind of what
consciousness is doing all the time.
You're laying out an
automatized routine and then if,
if that doesn't produce
the intended outcome,
you stop.
You become conscious really
because nothing like an
error to make you conscious.
Then you do a high resolution analysis
of the space in which the error emerged.
You rematch your motor output,
your perceptions and all of that to make
that error go away in a way you go and
so your consciousness is continually.
Your consciousness seems to be
continually building your unconscious,
your procedural unconscious,
and so to some degree,
the purpose of consciousness is to
make you functional unconsciously,
right?
Because that's way better.
You don't want to be conscious
if most things because it's just,
what are you going to do?
Be Conscious of your digestive processes.
It's like,
no,
if you're good at something,
you hardly have to be
conscious of it at all.
So.